foreign
to be pretty forgetful but my husband
when we fight he's been kind of like
bringing up my forgetfulness and you
know making it seem sad basically how
can I just help him understand where I'm
coming from
[Music]
what up what up hey what's up this is
John with the Dr John deloney show
so glad that you're with us the greatest
show literally it's ever been recorded
ever ever
and you showed up and I'm so grateful uh
on the show we talk about mental health
marriage whatever's going on in your
life actually
um all the things uh if you want to be
on the show
I'm not saying I'm very good at this but
if you want to hang out and chat on the
phone
um give us a buzz you can do one of two
things you can go to John deloney.com
ask ask fill out the form or you can
give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 leave a
message and we'll get back to you and uh
I said this last time and I want to say
it again
um we put out just a call for folks to
write in and give some feedback for the
show I just want to say thank you for
that those of you who had some
criticisms thank you for that those of
you who just wrote in to say really nice
things thank you
um those who did both I'm I'm just so
grateful
um and there was a lot of important call
outs
um how it sometimes comes across that I
I am too nice to women doing dumb things
and I'm too mean to men and I I don't
get the balance right sometimes that I'm
I'm yelling all the time for no reason
so there's some great feedback and a lot
of it was really accurate and so
um I'm taking it under advisement and
I'm gonna do my best to make a more
palatable show
and the horse noises May return that's
all I'm gonna say about that
um all right let's go to Sacramento
California and talk to Kayla what's up
Kayla
hey can you hear me I can can you hear
me
I can hear you great
excellent what's up
um first of all thanks for taking my
call and thank you Jenna for giving me a
call
um I am like super nervous right now I
like never understand why anybody's
nervous when I listen to your show and
now that I'm here I'm like oh my gosh
okay listen it's just you and me and
like
millions of other people listening to
this it's not about right it's not a big
deal not scary at all exactly uh so okay
so I think I'm going to just give
a little Crown first and then ask my
questions because it'll make a little
bit more sense that way cool but
basically what I'm calling is
um I have a tendency to be pretty
forgetful
um and
um nothing I mean to me that seems like
out of the norm or you know crazy like
you know I forget where I put things and
we get to respond to texts or send texts
to people
um I'm a stay-at-home mom so you know
during doing certain things around the
house
um non-routine appointments sometimes I
forget those
um and then you know like if I'm meeting
up with a friend I just blank on
everything that we talked about last
time we hung out so anyways
um
but my husband recently has been when we
fight he's been kind of like bringing up
my forgetfulness and you know making it
seem super
um
like bad basically and
um you know he's like I think the reason
why you're forgetting things is because
uh they're not priorities
um and if you just prioritize things
better then you wouldn't forget
um in in my mind you know I'm thinking
okay well
I'm a stay-at-home mom I have two babies
under two and I already struggle with
like anxiety
um and you know especially when I get
super stressed out and I'm having a
conversation with him
um I just freeze up and you know when he
asks me something to remember back to
you know another event I blink I'm like
I have no idea so
anyways basically what I want to know is
you know like could he be right is there
something that I'm not seeing um I
genuinely want to know and
um also how can I just help him
understand where I'm coming from
especially when we're in Conflict when
we're
um fighting I guess awesome great
questions
um so a couple of quick background
questions do you have a trauma
background or no
uh what I mean to find trauma I mean my
parents were divorced and I would say
yes like it was a kind of a catastrophe
my dad describes it as
um for all of my siblings okay I just
wanted to play this out how you told
that
um I think this is important
um uh Define trauma I mean they're
divorced my dad calls it a catastrophe
right
um so we don't have to dig into all that
here's
um
I'm trying to figure out the right place
to start I'm gonna get a little bit
nerdy and I'm gonna try to keep it as
non-nerdy as possible and just know when
I do this my Neuroscience friends all
send me direct messages and they're like
oh my gosh you blew it alone okay so
just know that I'm not gonna make
anybody happy with this but I think it's
important
um okay
the amygdala and the hippocampus are
these little parts of your brain that
help deal with your body's fear response
okay and um hippocampus Works does other
things like memory and spatial
functionings like where are you and it
helps influence emotional regulation all
this stuff but here's what's important
that the parts of your brain that are
are closely are dealing with is this a
fear is this a threat is there too much
coming into the system at once are also
where a lot of your brain does its
memory storage and retrieval
and that makes sense over time and
memories uh scattered throughout the
brain that's not those aren't the only
two places but here's why that's
important
um think of it this way you can be
watching a football game and you can
look at the game and be like why aren't
they scoring and somebody would look at
you and say Well they're playing defense
right now
like the offense isn't even on the field
they're trying to not let the other team
score right now
and so if you think about a world that
is a body that has been negotiating
trauma for a long time
a body that's anxious
a body that
um has two little kids and is trying to
figure out what just happened to my own
body what happened to my life what
happened to my marriage what happened to
all these things
you have a brain that is decidedly
trying to not die right now and the
thought that it's gonna spend energy
making new memories and remembering
things that aren't about not dying
it's very common for people who struggle
with anxiety to have short-term memory
like I just forgot that thing I just I
blew right past it because you got a
body that's just sprinting and fighting
and running for its life that makes
sense
yeah yeah that makes sense
and
okay so and
your husband's got a point
you can't be in relationship if you
forget things all the time
you can't be in a relationship with
somebody else if they have they pour
their heart out to you and you just let
it
you don't do the things Upstream that
make it make you able to hear those
conversations and connect
same with your friends same with
doctor's appointments and so I'm gonna I
want to give you a context not an excuse
okay
you and I could probably spend a couple
hours together and you could tell me
some stories from your pastor that would
probably blow my mind right fair enough
yes okay
um
I want you to know you're not broken
you're not screwed up you have a brain
that's just trying to protect you and it
probably has been for a long time
and
you're a wife
you signed up for a lifetime
relationship you got two little kids you
signed up for two lifetime relationships
and you're just probably a pretty good
friend too right
yeah I try
what a flex like yeah I mean I try all
right so
um
the healing's gonna be in two ways here
number one
you have to work towards building a
non-anxious life
and that's really hard with two little
kids what does that look like that
probably looks like you for the first
time in your life saying needs out loud
saying I need help with
could you be a part of this I don't like
it when you fill in the blank I really
need a night off tonight
how good are you at saying your needs
out loud
actually I'm pretty good
um
who knows I'm pretty vocal about my
needs
um I just kind of grew up in a family
like that
um can I are they are they needs are
they demands
that's a good question because I could
demand the dishes get put away in the
right way
that's different than I need some help
yeah I I try my best to format us
questions because I know you know I want
to respect him and I want to you know
not just bully him around but um okay so
I'm gonna stop right there that's the
problem
and people listening are gonna go what
asking questions and being kind
asking questions can be really really
past passive aggressive
okay
and I would much rather a couple sit
down not in a fight not in a discussion
but say all right we're entering into
it's Sunday night we're entering into
this week what does this week look like
calendar wise what's this week look like
budget wise
like how are you doing what how can I
love you best this week
and then it's hey would you pick up the
dishes if if I walk in after a wild day
of recording shows and doing interviews
and I walk in
um and then my wife's like hey would you
do that's different than
that because what she's she's not saying
would you she's saying do this and she's
wrapping it up in a nice
pretty package
it would be much I would love to have
some headspace that suggests that I'm
like hey uh I know when I get home I'm
gonna still be fully on and I'm Gonna Be
Still fully participating because we've
already talked about this because she
texted me at 3 P.M saying today's been
hell I need some help when you get home
awesome I'm in see what I'm saying so I
would suggest figuring out a way to be
more direct and y'all do this together a
lot of times folks who have not been
direct but they just talk around it
directness comes out really sharp and
hard and then the other person's like
whoa right so it's just learning how to
say like here's what I need in in a
I guess it's all good just normal
context right
um here's here's the other thing
um
I want you to get really intentional
about writing things down
if you know you struggle with
remembering things then I'm gonna put it
on you to start making plans for how you
can remember things better it's why I I
struggle with anxiety I always I have
for years
I always carry a note card with me
what's with with what's going on today
I just keep it with me all the time
because my memory is not trustworthy
I've learned that I forget everything
impact and I still got to change the oil
and I still got to show up to my kids
game and I still gotta go pick up my
daughter from whatever because I said I
would that make sense
yeah so when I say that does that sound
like an attack or is that um do you or
do you know like all right that's fair
you say like
um my husband I don't really know how to
describe this like
it kind of takes me off guard honestly
when if like he did take something
offensive
um you know if I were to like ask him to
do something or whatever
um I think he would prefer me to ask him
um rather than demand it because he's
kind of like this guy that's like you
know I want to feel respected as like
the man of our relationship and
um anyway so asking him to do things
um I don't think he really Minds it
um and he usually responds pretty well
um
however
there is something actually as they were
um talking that I remembered is
um one I think our most recent argument
that we had
I was like you know after he was telling
me you know you're forgetting these
things and you're just not prioritizing
you know whatever it was that you said
um he was like uh or I asked him I'm
like can you help me remember you know
can you
um you know because I tried to set
reminders on my phone and
um you know or have him text me a text
message and I'll just leave it unread so
I can always have it on my phone
notifications
um so I try to do things it's just with
our little ones it's not always like
like I'm super distracted all the time
so
um anyway so I asked him I'm like hey
you know can you just remind me you know
like you obviously know that's not the
strengths of mine but it is of yours you
know is that something that you can help
me with and his response to me was you
know I can't just always be doing that
for you and you know like you need to be
self-sufficient and
um you know like I could probably help
you here and there but you you have to
like figure it out pretty much and I was
just like
like when he said that I was honestly
just pretty hurt by it you know because
I'm like okay you're my husband I
thought we're supposed to try and be a
team here and you know it's something
that
you're asking you're asking him to be a
parent
yeah and I want you to start leaning
into this is gonna sound crazy I want
you to start leaning into
not having your life dragged around by
two toddlers
the greatest gift you can give those two
toddlers to infants is you make sure
you're well and I know they got to eat
on a schedule and they gotta sleep I get
that
but the number of kids who run their
households and their parents are left
Haggard and beat down in the wake of
what these kids are demanding and
needing and wanting and all
it's chaos I want you to flip around and
take ownership of that that doesn't mean
you're not going to be exhausted of
course you are doesn't mean you're not
gonna be frustrated of course sure you
got two little ones
but I want you to be on top on the on
the front end of it not just a passive
recipient and when you ask um and and I
didn't I didn't word this right I'm not
saying make demands of your husband
there's a difference between barking
orders
and
passively because here's a good example
you said would you just remind me
and he said no
and you didn't have a comeback for that
other than you were just hurt by it
and so when you ask a question you're
inviting somebody to give their feedback
right they give their answer and that's
not what needs are needs are a gentle I
need some support and help here
and you're also asking them like I said
you're asking me to be your dad hey will
you tell me when school starts we remind
me to change my underwear and to put on
deodorant brush my teeth like that like
so there is partnership and there is
working together and there's there is
this is a wild season I would much
rather you sit down and say hey I'm
really scared about this
motherhood is is is harder on me than I
thought it was going to be
um I need some help around here I want
to hire some help around here I need a
week once a week I need to go spend some
time with some girlfriends and just not
have kids all over me I need to fill in
the blank like I need these things our
life is really over scheduled right now
and I need a way to take some take some
of the things off the calendar I often
um and there's some great research on
clutter and anxiety
I often am guilty of leaving
a bunch of unread emails a bunch of
unread texts on my phone and it starts
to make me bananas right it's not
actually helping my brain is still
running got to do that thing gotta do
that thing gotta do that thing and then
I'm on to the next thing and I'm on to
the next thing and then I get another
text another text another text and so
many of them I've just had to start
saying I'm not going to get back to this
one and I'll just mark it on red
but that's me taking ownership of my
calendar there's two or three unreads
right now and I'll get them before the
end of the day that's that's kind of my
24 hour rule with myself but the more
you allow these things to build and
build and build and build and build
you're just signaling to your about
you're creating a world your body can't
exist in just too much just too much too
much too much too much too much so if
you think about unread messages if you
think about about unread texts or
unresponded to emails
just think of somebody knocking on your
door and you don't answer it and you're
just gonna let them keep knocking
because you'll answer them later and
then somebody else starts ringing the
doorbell and then somebody else just
starts yelling through the window and
somebody else just starts calling your
phone
you can't do anything after that and
that's what's happening inside your head
when you just let stuff go let stuff go
let stuff go all I have to say is this
you've created a very anxious world for
yourself and that's super common with
toddlers
and now your husband's getting
frustrated because his world looks
different you're frustrated because your
world looks different and it's time for
you and your husband to get together and
create a whole new world
a whole new planet for how we're gonna
operate here and I want you to practice
remembering practice writing things down
practice leaning into those things and
also practice saying your needs in a
kind gentle way not in a demand way not
in a catching somebody off guardway but
letting people know ahead of time and
um if you find that you're being gaslit
on some things
that your husband's like oh you forgot I
said that maybe he didn't maybe he
didn't and that's where writing things
down is important because you can come
back and if he's kind of jerking you
around a little bit that's important too
um but you're not crazy
you're like an exhausted mom that the
world's just happening to and I want to
encourage you to get some women in your
life that you can walk alongside and
begin to get on top of this of the crest
the wave here right so the water's not
just blasting in the face press the wave
here
and then you can start to take ownership
of the calendars take ownership of these
kids routines take ownership of what you
need in your home and asking for those
needs
ownership of I forget stuff a lot so I'm
going to start leaning into some
practices where I can start remembering
things a little bit better you're on the
right path you're on the right path
thanks for the call Kayla we'll be right
back
I've got a word from our sponsor
betterhelp listen I've been on both ends
of therapy in my life I've gotten it
myself and I've walked people through it
and I've seen the benefits from both
sides when someone owns their past and
the cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right we are back hey a few weeks
ago if you remember if you listen to all
the shows
um I had a call schedule with a
firefighter and right before he came on
he got called to an actual fire and so
we rescheduled the call and he is here
what's up Neil how we doing brother
how you doing doctor thanks for your
time of course man thank you for your
time and thank you for taking care of
our communities when I'm sound asleep
and my kids are sound asleep I'm
grateful for you man
yeah I uh first and foremost I do need
to apologize I know it's a tough I put
you in the tough spot
um who literally was my neighbor
you're fighting fires I run my mouth on
a on a on a b-rated podcast the art our
job comparison is of no comparison
Kelly's like no this is an a this is not
an a this is hey Kelly it's not an a yes
it is I'm gonna say it today this is a b
at best thank you Neil
man you do your thing Neil and we'll
reschedule every single time we need to
so what's up man
I uh so I called in a couple of weeks
ago when you're on the Dave Ramsey Show
and and I'm sorry I even called in a
little late on that show I wish we I
would have had a few more minutes to
talk because it does kind of concern
both of you uh if you will yeah
um I I followed the Dave Ramsey program
um we're doing well uh we've got a good
job we've eliminated debt minus the
mortgage and so as we continued on that
path what's happened over the last two
or three years because of
um just this role that I play with the
fire department
um we've encountered a number of
children who have passed pass on scene
and unfortunately I've been on a lot of
those calls
um and so
as that has happened it's put me in this
mindset where I'll come home and the
kids will say and I have I have four
daughters which is just beautiful
wonderful and they'll say Hey Dad I
really want to see this or do that um I
want to go there and because I'm in this
mind sign
um I I just kind of book it and go and
so I'm kind of breaking my policy
with what I've done with my death
I've broken into a few of my um
savings accounts and made sure that I
had that time and that memory with my
kids
and I I always tell so I beyond being a
firefighter I have a full-time job and I
tell my team when you before you come to
me I want you to ask yourself one
question is the house on fire or are we
out of coffee
keep it simple right and so at this
point I'm a little nervous with where
I'm at I feel like this fire is at the
incipient stage and uh I feel like it
could progress so I'm trying to head it
off and that's why I called I love that
man
um and I I I take so many calls on this
show and then also on that show that
very few of them stick with me long term
and yours did in fact I took some time
the following day
um our call that we had together and if
you want to go back we'll link to that
call in the show notes here if you want
to go back and listen to the original
call I was on the show with Dave Ramsey
and you called in
brother I had in talking to you I had
some memories of some situations that I
hadn't thought about in years
and I got a little girl too and it was
like I I was I I had some time I just
been with myself right so let me ask you
a broader
um zoom out picture here
the the picture you're painting is of a
guy
um
who has a lot going on
and a guy who is constantly being called
up for service to his family you're a
great father
your great husband
a great firefighter you're also a
business leader and you do good at that
and the one person that you've left off
the helping list is you
am I right or wrong
yeah I think I said the last time I'm
the guy you called for help not when I'm
not the one to call for help you know
right exactly yeah yeah
I forgot that I said that like most
firefighters
hey I just want to call it out what it
is
um most firefighters are told
if you have a problem come see your
supervisor go to your chain of command
and nobody in the world in that in a
first responder situation is going to go
tell their boss they're struggling with
anxiety or struggling with depression or
hey I've seen too many kids passed away
this month I can't do it I need to I
need a break can't do that because
they're gonna kick you off to death Duty
You're Gonna Roll you all off of Patrol
they're gonna end so you just gotta sit
on it
or they give you some counselor that has
got a reporting line to some right so
you just say they so folks say nothing
and then you know the amount of First
Responders who are struggling with
substance abuse who cheat on their
spouses who are have all sorts of other
issues going on in their lives and I'm
convinced beyond a shadow of a doubt
because they see this stuff all day long
and there's nowhere to go
and I'll you are too valuable to not
take care of my friend Neil
so my question how do you do that
or what let me ask this why won't you do
that I'll just be super direct why won't
you do that
well if I had a chance to read your book
and one of the questions that you pose
early on
um like after World War II we have this
abundance of money and credit and people
were able to get what they want now they
could get it at an implant and that has
never really left our culture our
society
um and you pose the question why
and so I thought about that and I have
been and so
I think about it
what if I lose this moment with my kids
and that's my why but I need to do this
now I need to make this memory now
because when we are doing something in
Florida or as a national park or
whatever
we're completely unplugged and we're
completely together but we're not that
when we're here at home when we're at
home we're running
why have you chosen that life
oh god
um
why not we're Americans right there you
go
so you you run in this country
I I I I know and
we've created worlds that we literally
have to escape from
we have to do everything
and we've created worlds that are so
abundant and so fast moving that we have
to pay more money to leave them
to get away from them
and that my friend is insane
yeah but here we are but here we are and
I don't
and I don't know what my next step is
because I since we've talked my kids sat
down and they talked about National Park
they were looking through this beautiful
books that we have and one of them said
I want to go to Glacier guess what
it's booked I've done that since we've
last talked yeah
and listen you know your kids know that
when you get to do something nice for
them it lights you up
and so they love it when dad's lit up
and so they're gonna find cool things
that they like and bring them to Dad so
that Dad lights up and then they feel
like they're bonding in that
relationship
if you go to a bunch of water balloons
and after school today and it cost you a
dollar 59 at Walgreens
and after school today I don't know how
much balloons cost maybe it's five bucks
um you had them in buckets
and your daughters came home all four of
them and you said you guys got three
minutes to hide
and it's game on
they would tell that story at your
funeral not the Glacier Park story
yeah I know
I know here's the thing
you're creating memories you're trying
to hedge against the fact that someday
something bad is going to happen to one
of your daughters
you're trying to hedge the fact that you
have seen these moms and dads that
cannot physically stand up because they
have fallen down at a crime scene
they've fallen down at a wreck scene
you've seen it you probably helped pick
them up right
yeah you ever held a mom who just lost
her baby lost her kid yeah it's a
different hug isn't it
yeah you can't breathe it's a strange
hug if there's a strength that I was
caught off guard the first time a woman
was saw her kid who had died and turned
and I was just happened to be there and
grabbed me with a hug that was of such a
ferocity that I I was caught off guard
by it
I didn't know strength could come from
that small of a person
it was like a I'm falling catch me hug
right
yeah
you're trying to hedge against that by
spending a bunch of money you don't have
and creating hype and hoopla and and
smoke and fireworks
for four little girls that just really
want their dad
yeah you and uh Dave mentioned that
doesn't doesn't cost anything
I don't know I I
there are just so many distractions I
mean in your book you outline you know
how many how many devices do you have
how much time are you on that screen and
how much time per day per week I I do I
think about that I consider that and
then I also I've even played the tough
guy like we're gonna shut down we are
going to take those devices we're gonna
play a board game
and we have we do that
but it's it's just it's not the
it's not the moment
that we have when when we're completely
disconnected when we are in a tent in
the middle of nowhere in the middle of a
park you there's no cell service there's
no nothing there's just us
and I I am desperately trying to
recreate that in my personal life and I
just don't know how to do it because it
we get those dings we hear the emails
like everything draws us and pulls us
away and then what's your other job
what's your other job
so I um I'm a director at the largest
publishing firm in the uh country
I'm gonna be super direct with you is
that cool
I have you're headed for an implosion my
brother
I have conversations with some of the
most intelligent people in the world
enlisted beautiful jobs it is it is
and you also know that some of those
people are hyper hyper intelligent and
they're Bonkers too
right
yeah so intelligence gets you part of
the way
um I'm gonna be super direct man you're
headed for an implosion you're headed
for a crash
I can hear it
you got on the treadmill and the
sucker's on 15 and it won't go any
higher and you can run no faster
and you don't know how to get off
and you're like you are killing it in
your other job
you're showing up in the middle of the
night doing gnarly things and you got
four dollars that you're trying to raise
and if you think about it the other way
maybe it's that those places that your
their daughters get you unplugged
finally
I I mean I was I was on the road this
week in Georgia
so on Sunday flew home Wednesday
I was in meetings until 5 PM
and then we have drills every Wednesday
night until 10 o'clock
so what are you running for man what are
you running from Neil
um
I don't I don't think I'm running here's
the deal is I I honestly God feel like
my my daytime job I love it because I
feel like I'm providing education to the
masses and we're doing a great job
because education is the way out for a
lot of people who especially have
economic boundaries right
um in the evening I'm waiting for my
pager to go off because somebody in my
community like my neighbor last week or
two weeks ago they needed help I can
help I have a helping hand and I can do
this
you're going to be of no help to anybody
when you're dead
Neil
after your fourth drink again
you're too smart for your own good
and you've wrapped your you've wrapped
your pathology and altruism you're a
great human being
and you use that as an excuse to not sit
at home and be still
yeah I don't
I'm not gonna argue that because you
don't think you have value in and of
yourself your value is only found in
your utility
is there a problem with that
truly yes I mean yes
because at some point because at some
point Neil you can't be that guy that
shows up or at some point your daughter
is gonna have a wedding and you're gonna
get a pager number I left my brother's
wedding to go deal with a car accident
and I will go to the Grave with that one
because I screwed that up
I said my role in my community is more
important than looking my brother and
saying I honor you I'm gonna spend the
day with you
on one of your most happiest days of
your life I missed it man I screwed it
up
because I put all my worth in this thing
that I do for other people
and I had taken had no worth in my
brother just wants me to sit by him at
his wedding and say this is incredible
let's dance and eat
I missed it
and the more we think that our only
values and what we do
the more we just Chase more things to do
and we get push that thing more and more
and more and more and more you're
talking to a dude with two phds man I
didn't get that because I'm super smart
I get that because I was running for
myself
and while I was getting a PhD I was
working full time as a dean of students
at a law school and I was also running
crisis calls in the middle of the night
absolutely
because I missed my son's childhood
I've got some great stories and I've got
some great experiences and I helped a
lot of people
and I missed some things that I could
never get back
well let me ask you this
how do we move forward from here I am
so ingrained in what I do
and I have a team of eight that
call and I and my team unfortunately I I
kind of have a unique circumstance with
my full-time job because I have a rep
down in Florida in Orlando and then I
also have a rep that's up in Spokane so
I am going from
seven until seven per se Neil you're and
I am listening you're a prisoner
you're a prisoner and your body tells
you the only way we can be free is on a
mountain with no cell service
man but it is beautiful there yeah it is
it's incredible it's amazing listen if
Dave Ramsey called me today and said hey
my buddy has uh a jet that's worth 10
million dollars and he's gonna sell it
and I talked to him into selling it to
you for 2 million it's a deal of a
lifetime
I would have to say that's amazing dude
I would love a 10 million dollar jet
that I could buy for two million dollars
I don't have two million dollars so I'm
gonna have to pass
the Glacier National Park is is
breathtaking stunning can't breathe it's
so beautiful and we can't afford it
created a uh you you've created your
prisons locked from the inside dude
here's here's the place to start
um
I want you to spend some time with that
question and since and I want to ask you
to write it down
what's Neil running from if if Neil
suddenly couldn't be a firefighter if
Neil suddenly lost his job as the book
publisher who is Neil
does that Neil have value
to his daughters to his wife
to his community
what I'll tell you is only because I
open up my hands and started trying to
be all stop trying to be all things to
all people only then could I truly show
up and be a gift
here's the deal I always thought that
there were these elements that people
had to fulfill throughout their life
that
it to continue on with this goal of this
dream this country what we're doing
our forefathers I mean it wasn't easy
like they there's there's time toil
blood that's all here
I want to continue that not just for me
but for everybody that comes behind me
that's fair and I do carry that weight I
carry that weight
earnestly I I wasn't in the military she
probably should have been
um but
I carry that and I carry that
every day and I want to make sure that
everything I do that everything behind
me is is a smooth or a smoother pass for
those evolved and here's the deal I love
that I love that and uh I remember
sitting down having a private
conversation with Jocko and I talked for
a while about that very same thing and
he told me John people for because I was
I was pushing him on it like man you run
and Gun you do all this and this and
this and he said something that was
really important for me to hear John men
throughout all of human history have
left their families for months or years
at a time to go defend a land
and he was right that's true
the question you have to ask yourself is
if that's your path then that's your
path I'm not going to take your path
from you
you want to die on the battlefield good
for you I'm I'm off go for it okay
that doesn't give license to be
irresponsible with your finances
so let me say this if you're going to
die on this battlefield
making the world better for everybody
else
um then go all the way and do it all
with integrity
and know that it's going to come at a
cost
you can't do all that stuff and not miss
games you can't do all that stuff and
not miss weddings you can't do all that
stuff and have your wife going to bed by
herself a lot you can't do all those
things and go on all the family
vacations too just can't yeah you gotta
choose
and if you're going to choose one you
got to make peace with the other
I think I'm here because I don't
I don't I don't want to keep going down
this path that's what I think I do I
agree with that I also know that in my
life I'm just speaking for me
when I start getting existential and
Global that's when my anxiety is at its
highest
and it is just looking for things to
spin up about
so I guess
I get you I'm asking okay
pray
um
I'm looking I mean you give me a Dave
Ramsey plan I will follow that day in
the day out step by step and we're going
to achieve and I did
how do I how do I like I don't know
how the heck you would even formulate a
plan for this scenario
what do I do I want you to get off the
phone and I want you to go to
psychologytoday.com
I want you to go through the list of
local counselors and psychologists in
your area
and just scroll down until you find one
that you read their little bio and think
this person is going to be this might be
the one for me I want you to make that
call
and when you sit down with the counselor
the psychologist and they say why are
you here
I want you to tell them I am an
executive I'm a firefighter and I saw
four dead children this month
and start there
and by the way if you want to be a real
gangster about it you can say
one of them where her name was Susan and
she was six
and one of us name was Stephen and he
was four he was wearing blue jeans let's
get real specific
that's where you start
and by the way you are uh
that's one of the truest marks of
Bravery I can I can account for
most people don't understand this but
it's it's easy to go run into an active
shooter situation when you're trained
for it
I honestly it's easy it becomes it
becomes part of your training you just
go right you just go right you're like
that dude you see a wreck you just go
I'm driving down the road and there's a
wreck my wife will literally I'll pull
over the car and she'll just start
sliding over in the driver's seat
because she knows her husband's getting
out
she just knows that right and I'm not
even a trained firefighter
courage is when it's scary
and sitting down in front of another
person and saying I'm not okay that's
real scary to somebody who's everyone
comes to for the answers
hey Neil here Neil she knows she knows
she's married to a uh as I put in the
book she's married to a taser
she knows
oh man why are you so scared to tell her
that I'm not okay
she knows you're not
yeah I know she though she thinks you're
dishonest man or worse she thinks she's
not trustworthy enough to be a part of
the parts that really hurt for you
nah she's she's laid some of this
framework here that I led up to this
conversation and good for her she's a
smart woman they are
you you love you some smarts
yeah
but I uh
I just I don't know when to call it and
that's right now that's what scares me
the most don't mate don't make an after
plan right now
the first plan is get out of the
building
so the first plane like you're trying to
like the house is on fire and you're
trying to start drawing up architecture
plans for the rebuild get out
that is a great analogy just call the
counselor call a psychologist and say I
need to talk
and you can say I don't buy into this
stuff I think this is for weak people
this is not for me
but here we are
I'm not all right
and here's the here's the beautiful part
when it all said and done
I actually work more hours than I used
to
crazy right
yeah I'm actually an infinitely better
dad and an infinitely better husband
I got more going on
the difference is those things that are
going on are not me trying to convince
myself that I've got worth and value
those things that are going on are now
things I can do freely because I'm
anchored into the Bedrock of my marriage
I'm anchored into the Bedrock of my
local community
and because I did that work
because I'm working hard to create a
non-anxious life where I'm not over
scheduled and overzealous and
overrunning and there's always
Electronics all the stuff that we've the
world we've created
because that's where the hard work is
now man I can go run if I need to do
something in the middle of the night and
show up somewhere weird I can go show up
somewhere that's fine I'll be tired the
next day that's cool because my identity
my Worth's not tied to it yours is
and I'm gonna tell you right now it's
gonna be a hard road It's A Hard Road to
untangle all that it's gonna be messy
messy messy messy messy and
I have one thousand percent confidence
that you can get there and I'm proud of
you and I'm I'm grateful for you I will
be with you every step of the way call
me anytime uh shoot me a direct message
and I'll I'll we can figure out a way to
communicate offline if you need to but
I'll walk alongside you can't be a
therapist or a counselor because I'm not
even one of those at all but I'll be
willing to pitch in where I can't man
your community needs you and your family
needs you
Neil needs you
grateful for you man we'll be right back
[Music]
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right let's take one more let's go
out to Jessica in Seattle what's up
Jessica
hi Dr John how are you good how are you
I am doing fantastic it's this feels a
little surreal I'm really happy to talk
to you I don't ever get to talk to
Seattle people it's the home place
that's the birthplace of uh Pearl Jam
and Allison Chains and all the good
soundgard it is we're just up here being
depressed so we can't get on the phone
to call you because the weather's so bad
I know we don't have any good music
coming out of Nashville because we're
all too busy being outside and enjoying
the weather and all that kind of all
that vitamin D see we're so we're so
Overjoyed we don't know what to do with
ourselves that's right that's right you
guys got to work on that well we will we
will all right so what's up
I want to ask you I don't hear a lot of
borderline personality questions from
what I've listened to you before I've
got a 70 year old mom with borderline
personality disorder
I am her only child
she is divorced
and I'm kind of watching her taking a
steep decline since she and my dad got
divorced
and I just need some advice from you on
what you think I should do or if I
should be doing any more that I'm
already doing who diagnosed her is that
a true diagnosis was that just off the
internet
or the therapist that she's been meeting
reviewed her notes
from when she was hospitalized maybe
like 30 years ago
and there was a BPD diagnosis in there
so not helpful okay
yeah so this is totally like very new
information for me but when I looked
into it completely checks out yeah
so one I don't like Cold Case
Diagnostics I don't like looking at data
from 30 years ago and trying to Retro a
situation okay okay here's why
um because 30 years ago they were not
asking questions about trauma they
weren't asking questions about
environment they weren't asking
questions about grief
so okay meaning you could do an intake
at some of these places and your husband
had just died
and they would ask you on the
questionnaire
are you having suicidal thoughts yes or
have are you struggling with this yes
are you struggling with this yes bam
diagnosis
okay and so there's I
I I don't she needs to go get checked
out now he's gonna sit with somebody now
if she will if she won't she won't he is
actively in in therapy or Counseling of
some sort now okay all right so let's
let's move over to she truly has
borderline personality disorder
um I'm of the opinion outside of of what
I would call true psychiatric disorders
like schizophrenia those are challenging
um but there's there's entire
Specialties there borderline personality
disorder is I think it's the toughest
thing to deal with both as a clinician
both as a family member both as somebody
suffering from borderline personality
disorder here's why yeah your core
signals are off
yes fear love
on my team against me those are so
um Amplified
in a way that okay I mean you if you
grew up with it and it's true then there
were days when your mom would hold your
face and look at you in the eyes and say
every day of my life I thank God that
you're my daughter you're the greatest
daughter that has ever existed
and as a 10 year old you can hardly
breathe because your chest is so puffed
up and you're you're so excited and then
later that afternoon your mom will sit
down and take a knee and say everything
about you disgusts me my life would be
so much better if you weren't here
and you as a 10 year older going uh
right is that is that is that track
um there were a lot of ups and downs I
think my mom did more sleeping than she
did like laying into me okay about
things so avoidance
she there it was either she was feeling
great and she was being crafty and
creative or she was sleeping or she was
down
yeah
okay
that doesn't that doesn't that doesn't
ring the the borderline bells to me but
we also had an opiate addiction
because why not right yeah Jessica lead
with that lead with that
um so I'm sorry there's so many layers
to this I wasn't sure even what to start
with okay I'm I'm messing with you I
know this is I I'm I'm trying to bring
some levity I know this is a mess
um so let's let's let's think outside
the diagnosis okay okay and that's
something with my one of my friends call
me when I'm just having a personal
conversation with my buddies that's one
of the most common things to say is like
let's think out of the diagnosis let's
just look at the world that's in front
of us okay all right you've got a mom
that is fill in the blank for me she's
what uh I have a mom who I haven't seen
in six months she lives five minutes
from me okay you haven't seen her
because she won't see you she's avoid
you you don't go over there she's a
hoarder because uh she is a hoarder uh I
think
for the holidays she opted out of the
holidays she said she wasn't feeling
well okay
uh she I didn't hear from her on my
birthday which this is the first year
that's ever happened okay
I think she's just in such a deep dark
place right now that she doesn't want
her grandkids to see her like that and
she doesn't want
um she just wants to tell us she doesn't
feel well to avoid any intervention we
think we might need to have with her
what has kept you from going to knock on
the door and say you're my mom and I
love you and you're not okay
um
I don't know if I have a solution to
offer her when she collapses and says
I'm not okay because she's told me she's
not okay for 43 years
and I don't feel equipped to solve
whatever problem she
it you know presents to me okay
um so one thing I would recommend you do
and and again I want to honor this
powerlessness I get it she's an adult
and there's nothing harder than seeing
people that we love who are adults
struggling and they don't invite us into
that conversation or they present us
they drop bricks in our backpack that I
don't know what to do with this I don't
have the training and all the skill set
I don't have anything like that right
yeah and so um I'm just gonna tell you
if this was my mom what I would do
because I don't have the
training to sit down and do borderline
personality disorder and at 70 I can't
imagine the entrenchment um I I've I've
never even read about somebody trying to
heal from borderline at 70. okay yeah I
I just walked alongside so many of my
college students and it was hard it was
really difficult because they had to
learn that when they felt scared that
they might not their bodies are lying to
them is basically you gotta you gotta
get to where I have to
step back from my emotions and
recalibrate and it's just hard it's
really hard to do
um so
if I'm you
I would reach out to her current
therapist do you know who that person is
no I don't okay
um I would do everything I could to find
out who that person is
okay
and they can't unless your your mom has
written a release to where you can talk
to that person they can tell you that
she's even a client
um okay they can take information One
Way meaning you can write her counselor
a letter
but in writing or an email
and say
my mom is expressing things in a way
that is making me think she's suicidal
or she is on a deep negative trajectory
yeah I'm very worried about her and I'm
interested in partnering partnering with
you if you think there is a need and a
counselor if there is a direct threat to
self or others can breach that
confidentiality it's a nuclear option
but they can do that
I'll also say if she's seeing somebody
and this person is competent and they're
licensed and all that stuff
right then they should be trained to
know I'm watching a trend line here that
is making me uncomfortable and making me
nervous I've got to reach out to
um some Lifeline that's right
okay I've got to reach out to a
psychiatrist or to a team or to a social
worker or a family or whatever yeah and
so um and it may be that you asked your
mom
um I'm not in a position I I don't I
don't know how to help you with your
addiction on how to help you with your
mental health stuff I would love to
partner with your counselor so that you
have support everywhere
that's a good suggestion and what she
can do is sign a release and give you
permission their counselor permission to
talk back and forth with you
okay
to right now I think that's she might be
open to that okay sometimes they will
write back and say
I am not currently seeing a client named
Kelly
yeah and sometimes that's a big
indicator right
often they'll say that indicator it's a
big indicator maybe your mom's not
seeing somebody you think she is oh yeah
yeah right or that she saw somebody
three years ago and that's quote unquote
her person and so she's going to
somebody right okay all I have to say is
this
um
I'd also wouldn't would reach out to
Social Services or local services in
your area that
help the elderly
possible have conversations about
Assisted Living if I don't know what
your finances are
um we're having broader conversations
now because we're 70 and mom's still
struggling with addiction and now she's
starting to shudder the doors trying to
disappear on us
um and again I hate this because Mom can
say leave me alone
oh my gosh leave me alone
and I can't think of a more
gut-wrenching horrible like situation to
be in
um so let's let's exhaust every possible
Avenue for support and care
you're not gonna be the therapist you're
not going to be the person writing
scripts you're not going to be the
person actually doing the care you're
gonna you might be the The Hub of the
wheel for a while
playing traffic cop playing direct like
if you talk to this person here I've
talked to this person but at the end of
the day unfortunately your mom's gonna
have to make some final decisions the
last option you got is to file a
petition with the local court that to
take away her
her rights that she is incompetent too
she's unable to make decisions for
herself
um she's a harm to sell for others and
you need to step in and that's going to
depend on man who is the who's your
caretaker you have to give your religion
sisters and have that conversation
that's a broader conversation and that's
a last option right because you're
saying this person can't take care of
themselves they can't make adult
decisions for themselves I need to step
in to be their caretaker
um and then the burden of proof is on
you to prove that this person can't do
that and that's that's a tough tough
road to hoe but
um I wrote a hoe but
just for what it's worth I'm grateful to
know people like you love their mom and
I know that's been a tough tough tough
life that you've lived with a woman
who's had a lot of strong really
struggle
um let's think outside the diagnosis
right now and focus Less on Googling
things about uh you know manic
depressive bipolar disorder or Googling
things about
um
borderline personality just all that
stuff and instead let's focus on
resources in our local community for
helping Mom
and bring in your brothers and sisters
in on this one I'm so sorry Jessica let
me know if I can help it any other way
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right this is a huge day Kelly what
is it it's not Taco Tuesday it's even
bigger it's the best day of the year
today is Texas's birthday
now I'd like to State for the record
Texas doesn't have a birthday it always
has existed
because we were our own country Before
Time began yes we're like Chuck Norris
but when The Mortals decided to
recognize us
I'm a Tennessean now I guess I live here
are you still claiming Texas
is still my home I've I've lived here
about equally as long in Tennessee but
I'm still a Texan it's it's ingrained
it's in your soul there's just a pride
there that people don't get good job
listen
[Laughter]
bless them
um
I I was in I think I told you I was at a
hunting trip in in uh in another state
and they were telling me like well we
can't do that on this land and we can't
do that on this land and I kept saying
this is your land and they're like yeah
we can't do that on this we can't do
that we have to call this person to do
this
and the text enemy was like they can't
tell you what to do on your land and
they're like uh they for sure can I was
like Revolt like
anyway they weren't having it so today's
song of the day as we wrap it up
the one and only Gene Autry
songs called deep in the Heart of Texas
and it goes like this
stars at night
big right
deep in the Heart of Texas
the Prairie Sky is wide and high the
coyotes whale along the trail the
rabbits rush around the brush the
Chicken Hawks are full of squawks the
oil wells are full of smells and so has
been and the cactus plants are tough on
pants
and that's why perhaps they all wear
chaps perhaps maybe not
the Cowboys cry
the doggies ball and say you all
the cactus plants are tough on pants
deep in the Heart of Texas
stay tuned
for more geography lessons love you guys
[Music]